shouldn't the law require kids to be
vaccinated we could listen to science
which says vaccines are safe and
effective or you know we could listen to
this lady it's unconstitutional it
violates the Nuremberg code it violates
education rights it violates parental
consent it violates the relationship
between a doctor and a patient she's
referring to a bill that just became law
in California parents can no longer
choose not to vaccinate their kids for
religious or personal beliefs if they
want to enroll them in the state schools
this law was passed in response to an
increasing number of parents choosing
not to vaccinate their kids when it
comes to preventing disease vaccines
play a big role they eradicated smallpox
polio and diphtheria in the US and are
close to wiping out 11 other infectious
diseases put to work effectively
vaccinations rely on what's known as
herd immunity if a certain percentage of
the population is vaccinated it makes it
difficult for these diseases to spread
and also protects the unvaccinated that
includes children too young to be
vaccinated and those who can't be for
medical reasons and the us kids are
required to get vaccinated before they
go to school but 19 states allow a
personal belief exemption letting
parents opt-out of vaccines for their
kids for any reason California which is
the center of the anti-vaccine movement
just closed this loophole
but why is there an anti vaccine
movement at all it started after a study
linked vaccinations to higher rates of
autism the paper published in 1998 has
since been discredited as a fraud
many newer studies have found no link
between vaccines and autism in fact the
rise in autism race has more to do with
better awareness and an expanded
definition of who falls on the autistic
spectrum science also debunks the claim
that vaccines contain toxic ingredients
another big anti vaccine argument both
the CDC and the FDA have
levels of mercury formaldehyde and other
ingredients are within safe levels and
while vaccines do carry a risk of
negative reaction it's incredibly small
less than one in a million people will
have a severe reaction to a vaccination
despite this celebrities like Jim Carrey
are vocal opponents of the new law and
some of the richest areas in California
have vaccination rates similar to some
of the world's poorest countries and now
vaccine preventable diseases are on the
rise again so should more states follow
in California's footsteps